hey everybody it's your number one
Swifty here Michael Knowles many of you
have asked me to to devote my cultural
Acumen to analyzing the latest Taylor
Swift song lavender Haze and so I will
do it as you know I have never
intentionally listened to a Taylor Swift
song in my life but
when the producers played one for me I
really liked it and I'd heard them at
parties and bars and clubs and things
like that but I I never really focused
on the lyrics and I really kind of liked
it so we'll see if lavender Hayes can
live up to that as well Mr Davey is my
producer tells me that there was a
hidden woke aspect to it I'll try to
parse that as well
Taylor take it away
[Music]
foreign
the homosexuals
[Music]
you've been talking
I'm damned if I do give a damn what
people say
[Music]
um
spiral get it off your chest
[Music]
right now go to expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show companies are not just
selling products anymore they're selling
you
I'm talking about how tech companies
enrich themselves by taking your
personal data they grab your web history
email metadata and video searches to
create a detailed profile on you and
then sell that off to the highest bidder
when you go online without a VPN ISP can
see every single website you visit they
can legally sell this information
without your consent to ad companies and
Tech Giants who then use it to Target
you when you use expressvpn your
identity is anonymized by a secure VPN
server so isps cannot see your activity
online your data are also encrypted for
maximum protection I love expressvpn
because it's so simple to use even I can
do it just fire up the app click one
button works on all your devices iPhone
laptop iPad even your Wi-Fi routers stop
letting strangers engage your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show this
is the only VPN that I trust
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show to
get three extra months free
expresvpn.com Michael Knowles show so
the image tree that you see from the
very beginning as she is rubbing her
hands on her Lover's back is this
imagery of the night sky
of space and the the image of space
would suggest to me as the lyric is
saying that she doesn't want to be tied
down she doesn't want that 1950s no
sir right why Taylor she's not going to
be tied down that's what everyone wants
from her why probably just because
they're so very impressive right not
because that that is most conducive to
human flourishing and has been for all
of human history no no it's because they
want to oppress her so she doesn't want
any of that she she wants what she wants
the lavender Haze so the word lavender
color is associated with homosexuals but
it doesn't seem like she's talking about
doing lesbian stuff you see both the the
heavens and then the sea so there's
another image of all these fish floating
around and the sea is also wide open and
free all sorts of weird things happen in
the sea there's all sorts of magical
nymphs and mermaids and weird kind of
monsters and animals and things and
there's no Society to bog you down in
the sea the only place where there's
Society is right there in the middle and
the middle is Earth the middle is where
we live and that's the only place where
you're not free and so she's constantly
looking up can I have the freeness of
the freedom of outer space can I have
the freedom of the ocean
I'm here but I I'm here on this Earth
with all these stretches but I'm still
trying to resist those strictures she
doesn't seem to realize by the end of
the song
that if you live on earth and you try to
live like you're in outer space or like
you live on water you're not going to
thrive you're going to die because she's
dead these are just different conditions
of life and here on Earth we have these
structures we have human society man is
a social creature in order to flourish
but some people don't want to get that
message okay that's what I took from it
is did I miss something super woke about
it what was the woke thing I missed
trans models stars is Taylor Swift's
love interest okay there we go all right
so I actually my gut was right going
back to my intuition that lavender
insinuates weird gay stuff it did it did
it's just it's so confusing because the
chick looks a lot like a guy which ties
in then to that broader theme of outer
space and the Sea where we can just do
whatever we want be whatever we want why
does that chick who is the transgender
person decide that she has to look
exactly like a hulking man from a from a
Calvin Klein ad why does she decide that
because even she even a transgender
radical type person recognizes that
there's something attractive about that
1950s and yet there's also this
this parallel desire to run totally free
away from all of these things so Taylor
tries to fabricate it too but I don't
know she doesn't seem very happy by the
end of the song and I don't I don't
think it quite worked okay send in your
weird trans pop songs next time and
we'll see you
during the next cultural analysis
[Music]